talking here as a head teacher in part
from the heads study at Epsom College
where I am the head and I think the a
level is absolutely right and long
overdue 70 years is a good Fair run for
aels Britain was a totally different
place when 70 years ago it was devised
we need to move towards a broader more
modern examination system call it
British Balor what you will and I think
he's right about education and I think
he's right to give urgency in education
which the Tes did very well at the
beginning of the 13 14 years under
Michael Gove under David Cameron AS
prime minister gave it huge urgency and
I think he's right to return to it
because there's been there have been 10
educational secretaries in the last 10
years which is of course absurd